we aim to provide maximum information to
the public about our recycling scheme to
make it easy and convenient for our
customers to recycle as much of their
waste as possible
we deliver an ongoing programme of waste
education to engage local schools and
communities in the reduction of waste we
carry our collections of waste and
recycling from over 56,000 households in
team bridge and our vehicles go out
every weekday morning collecting
recycling and black bin waste all dry
recyclables are sorted onto the curbside
vehicles by our crews and delivered to
our Newton Abbot bulking station to be
segregated and transported to
reprocessing facilities all of the
material from Green wheelie bins gets
taken to a large composting facility and
the black bin waste goes to a nearby
landfill site we send out five
mechanical sweeper vehicles in the early
mornings to clean up the main town
centres and our parish sweepers go out
to rural towns and villages to keep the
streets clean and empty litter bins a
separate team the sponsor fly-tipping
incidents picking up waste has been
dumped in public areas there were 39
public toilets across team bridge and we
are responsible for their cleaning and
maintenance our toilets are assessed
annually for cleanliness and general
standard in recent years we've won
numerous loo of the Year awards with
many achieving a five-star grading we
continue to strive for maximum recycling
a minimum waste in team bridge and aim
to maintain our top ten position in the
national chance for recycling
performance and waste reduction